you guys are a huge global business you
have an office in Turkey there's been
events unfolding there what does
instability like that mean for your
business yeah we I still don't stage
three years ago and told our team i
equated it to a writing a different
roller coaster every week because you
don't know where the twists and turns
are and that that's a new world that we
live in and so you know whether it's a
the constantly changing geopolitical
landscape the economic shifts that occur
the technology transitions these are
just things that we all have to deal
with I think you know there's there's
certainly a tremendous loss of life
which is the real issue and it's
incredibly sad we see so much tragedy
around the world right now that it's
disheartening but we take all the things
that are going on geopolitically from
the global economic perspective we focus
on the things we can control we quickly
assess what the implications are for us
and then we move on what about briggsy
what does that mean for your global
outlook well first of all I think I
think Briggs it was unfortunate for the
European Union because they were moving
towards continuing to try to create a
single market right they had created a
single trading market and then
effectively trying to create a single
digital market going forward so I think
you know from that perspective it has a
potential to set them back but for us
you know we don't have operations in the
UK that we necessarily use to do
business across Europe so for us the
global implications are the macro
implications of that are probably
similar to what other countries would
see and obviously the currency situation
creates some challenges but otherwise
we'll navigate our way through with our
customers I was on this morning with
with a customer in the UK and we
continue to stay very close there and
we'll continue to invest there so I know
you normally vote Republican some other
folks in Silicon Valley who normally
vote Republican have said Donald Trump
is not someone that they can get behind
can you well Emily as I think about this
what we care about are the policies that
the candidates represent and so we're
going to focus on the policies
regardless of who gets elected because
our employees our customers our business
there are things that are critically
important to us there's you know issues
of inclusion there's
there's tax reform there's immigration
reform there's patent reform there are
all these things in that matter and when
I spend time in Washington with either
side of the aisle those are the things
we focus on us we're going to stay